heute bin ich eingeladen bei der großen
wahlparty der partei menschliche welt
[Musik]
wir sehen uns vom fernsehen größere
hallo schuhe ausgezogen schuhe aus ja
klar
jetzt mal kurz halten meinte ich gerne
was ist der erste programmpunkt wir
setzen uns im kreis und danach würden
dann musik machen und singen und
zusammen meditieren und danach etwas
essen und trinken ja und wie bei jeder
anderen partei waren ist ja
fassbieranstich
wir haben apfelsaft und wasser und tee
spiel mal das spiel mal durch sie
bekommen so einen zuspruch dass die
regierungsverantwortung übernehmen
würden könnten sich so etwas überhaupt
vorstellen 2049 plant ihr können wir uns
vorstellen an der regierung teilzunehmen
also wenn sie so äußerungen von horst
seehofer hören wie können sie da noch in
ruhe meditieren
wenn ich mich in seine kinderschuhe
hineinversetzen wie er erzogen wurde und
all das was er erfahren hat dann kann
ich verstehen wir das tut was er gerade
tut und ich möchte auch nicht nur
verstehen ich möchte auch in der lage
sein jeden menschen zu lieben das heißt
also sie sind in der lage horst seehofer
zu lieben ja ich möchte ihnen leben und
verstehen und ihn lieben ja das nenne
ich nächstenliebe
wir sind hier im frankfurter römer wer
sind sie denn mein name ist alexandra
monja muss und ich bin die
landesvorsitzende hier von der fau
partei in hessen hoch 3 also fatah m3
und was sind jetzt also partei hoch drei
das heißt wir stehen für veränderung
vegetarier und veganer ich komme jetzt
mal so an ich bin so ein typischer
veganern wähler ihrer partei sagen hallo
grüß euch mensch das war ein tag heute
mit der wahl habe ich habe keine wurst
essen können kein fleisch essen können
ich bin total fertig das einzige was ich
habe ist jetzt hier so was
das ist doch kein leben ich bin
fleischesser fleischfresser
leidenschaftlich kann kann kann ich sie
trotzdem wählen
ich würde sagen ja also mein
lebensgefährte ist auch fleisch aber wie
ist es so wenn man da so
zusammengestellt und und zusammen
vielleicht auch intim wird und sich
küsst und sie beim zungenkuss match
reste bei immerhin 10 ihres mannes ist
ein ganz gutes thema als erstes mal matt
ist da gar nicht mehr weil ich ihnen
gesagt habe das geht überhaupt nicht und
dann ist ganz klar nach fleisch essen
zähneputzen also hardcore veganer sind
wir natürlich nicht sondern wir können
uns durchaus koalitionen mit anderen
politikern vorstellen oder peter
altmaier liebt es zum beispiel dinge mit
leberwurst zu füllen wissen sie das
so leute wer ist denn nicht der chef
gibt es überhaupt ein
haben sie schon aktuelle zahlen wie
viele leute haben sie gewählt
ganz viele mehr also in frohnhausen
sechs stück sechs leute ja also ich
finde das ist das ist sechs ganz so
wähler eine stolze leistung die haben ja
auch ein menschenbild böse so ein
bisschen nimmt in dem vollkommenen
menschen irgendwie anstreben dass er sie
bildet das hat dass er dass er sich
irgendwie in seiner ganzen ganzen in
seinem ganzen wesen irgendwie ein
besserer mensch wird ein mündiger mit
aufgeklärter mensch wenn sie da diese
kamera schauen da schon jetzt millionen
leute zu und sie können jetzt haben
jetzt die chance fünf sekunden 18
sekunden ab
so sagen was sie besser machen werden
wenn sie einmal eines tages deutsche
kanzlerin sein werden aber wir werden so
vernünftige politik machen dass es
wirklich spaß macht war wieder jetzt
heute um zu lesen und im fernsehen zu
gucken und den noch interviews zu freuen
haben sie schon mal gesehen dass jemand
den löffel der nutzer gesagt dafür
sondern zurücklegen also sowas werden
wir verbieten
und mit diesen schönen bildern könig
zurück ins studio
warum